[Música]
sí
una imagen histórica
el 22 de enero de 1972 el primer
ministro británico edward hit firma el
ingreso de reino unido a la comunidad
económica europea
aunque londres ya había intentado
ingresar a la comunidad en dos
oportunidades bloqueadas por el
presidente francés charles de gaulle el
euroescepticismo estuvo presente desde
el inicio en 1974 el partido laborista
prometió que si ganaba las elecciones la
gente podría decidir en las urnas si
quería seguir perteneciendo al mercado
común el 5 de junio de 1935 el gobierno
del primer ministro harold wilson llevó
a cabo el referéndum pese a que la
decisión en esa oportunidad fue
permanecer los euroescépticos no se
detendrían en su aspiración por romper
con europa el más popular de ellos
nagel farage un político que se abrió
camino como líder del ala más dura de
los partidarios de abandonar europa me
gusta la cultura europea pero odio la
bandera odio el himno odio las
instituciones en 2015 la historia se
repetiría pero en esta oportunidad fue
el gobierno conservador de david cameron
el que basó su campaña electoral en la
promesa de un nuevo referéndum
anunciando que haría campaña porque el
reino unido- permaneciera en una unión
europea reformada una vez reelegido el
primer ministro cumple
y el 23 de junio de 2016 el pueblo
británico después de una turbulenta
campaña marcada por la propaganda y los
pequeños elige salir de la unión europea
al día siguiente cameron duramente
criticado dimitir pero ayunos en vigor
creo que sea correcto que yo intenté ser
el capitán que dirija a nuestro país
hacia su próximo destino para maniobrar
el barco a la deriva los conservadores
la eligen a ella
theresa me llega al número 10 de downing
street con una misión difícil por
delante el 28 de marzo de 2017 la
primera ministra firma la carta en la
que invoca el artículo 50 del tratado de
lisboa y en la que informa a las
autoridades de bruselas de la intención
de su país de abandonar la unión europea
a partir de ese momento londres y
bruselas se fijaron un plazo de dos años
para acordar los términos de la salida
del reino unido de la unión europea
buscando consolidar al partido
conservador male anuncia elecciones
anticipadas para junio de 2017 pero la
jugada no les sale bien de los 330
escaños que tenían los conservadores
pierden 12 y ahora deberán buscar
alianzas para formar un gobierno sus
nuevos socios serían los unionistas de
irlanda del norte durante 2017 y
principios de 2018 las conversaciones
con la unión europea continúan pese a
que en todo momento may se muestra
optimista su propio partido empieza a
darle la espalda casi una veintena de
sus altos funcionarios renuncian y su
popularidad se viene a pique el 14 de
noviembre de 2018 londres y bruselas
alcanzan un principio de acuerdo sobre
el break city
5 del mismo mes los 27 miembros del
bloque comunitario lo aprueban entre el
15 de enero y el 29 de marzo de 2019 las
propuestas de acuerdo de mail sufren
cuatro contundentes derrotas en la
cámara de los comunes
si es a la derecha 242 no es a la
izquierda 391 este día se cumple la
fecha límite que se habían fijado las
partes para llegar a un acuerdo y tras
los traspiés sufridos la premier pide
prórrogas a bruselas en dos ocasiones la
unión europea decide dárselas basados en
el artículo 50 es hasta el 31 de octubre
perfecto
sin embargo acorralada dentro de su
propio partido el 24 de mayo may dimitir
lo hago sin mala voluntad con una
gratitud enorme y duradera por haber
tenido la oportunidad de servir al país
que amo
una de las imágenes más representativas
de este proceso los parlamentarios
británicos progre excitan la espalda al
himno de la unión europea
el elegido por los conservadores para
completar el break si es el ex alcalde
de londres y ex ministro de exteriores-
boris johnson saldremos de la unión
europea el 31 de octubre sin peros el 29
de agosto johnson toma una de las
decisiones más polémicas del proceso y
suspende el parlamento para que la
oposición no vete un break sheet sin
acuerdo el cierre desata una situación
caótica en el país con llamados de la
oposición a los británicos a tomar las
calles el 17 de octubre johnson y
bruselas llegan a un acuerdo sobre uno
de los puntos más polémicos el manejo de
la frontera entre irlanda del norte y
parte del reino unido e irlanda miembro
de la unión europea
juntos hemos logrado un resultado justo
y razonable
nuevamente la palabra final la tiene el
parlamento del reino unido que el 19 de
octubre se reúne en una sesión
extraordinaria por primera vez en muchos
años un sábado los parlamentarios
británicos votan para retrasar la
decisión argumentando que necesitan más
tiempo para estudiar su contenido
johnson pide una tercera prórroga
bruselas con fecha límite del 31 de
enero de 2020 tras cuatro intentos
johnson logra finalmente el apoyo del
parlamento a la convocatoria de
elecciones anticipadas en diciembre
el premier logra la mayoría más
aplastante del partido conservador desde
la era thatcher con 364 escaños
y con este mandato y esta mayoría
finalmente podremos hacer que
en enero de 2020 tanto el parlamento
británico como el europeo dan luz verde
al plan de johnson entonces el 31 de
enero llega la tan esperada fecha para
los partidarios del break sito
[Aplausos]
la pandemia frena en gran parte las
conversaciones y nuevamente en diciembre
del 2020 se reactivan con los esfuerzos
para llegar a un acuerdo cuando parece
que el tiempo se agota el día de navidad
las dos partes anuncian que han llegado
a un acuerdo comercial ambas partes
enfrentan retos inmensos para mantener
la armonía en el nuevo escenario en
especial boris johnson que ha
reivindicado para los partidarios del
president de la soberanía británica
deberá demostrar que la salida de la
casa común europea después de casi medio
siglo de compartirla no acarreará una
desmejora de las condiciones de sus
ciudadanos